hey guys I'm gray I'm John Jackalope 777
century you guys seen the trailer for
the hero starring Sam Elliott if not
please reacts Sam Elliott he's a cowboy
Lone Star barbecue sauce the perfect
partner for your chicken lows Lone Star
barbecue sauce they want to give you a
Lifetime Achievement Award like anything
else job offer the script - what are you
doing I guess it's been a while
that's a good choice I gotta find you
give me a heart attack
close the continent are you of goodness
Ron swans little off a big one filled or
a prevalent that was 40 years ago
attention
we Charlotte Charlotte Lee first am i
trying to figure people up so what you
figure out about me because this seems a
little if you've got a problem with it
[Music]
Wow give me a chance to write another
job
cowboy and Retta remember for one person
here
[Music]
oh yes Folgers
answers in your cup you know what I love
most
what do you love Gregg I love that the
thumbnail for this on almost everything
you type in are used to is Krysten
Ritter that's what we call clickbait
people yeah good that's clickbait that's
some good quick babe you got a movie
that's all about Sam Elliot a little bit
to do a cursory thing there's a nice
surprise though it was a nice surprise
yeah that looks like it looks like a
good damn good drama do not get it
confused of the movie hero starring
Dustin Hoffman and gently and gently
dude let's remake rush hour this looks
like a really good drama though and he's
like well movie out cried during and be
like oh I'm really glad I saw them yeah
it looks like a sad film they'll break
your heart at times would also have lift
you it's kind of like if the wrestler
wasn't gonna make you feel like had a
little bit more than a light-hearted
humor in people's personalities yeah if
the if the wrestler wasn't so depressed
yeah it might be like this yeah that's
interesting a failing actor
I like that moment he gets off for a
Lifetime Achievement Award hey like me
who is not satisfied where he's out in
life you know he's not getting script
offers and stuff that's scary there's so
many actors that we love that we just
don't see anymore because that happens
to so many actors I wonder how this
movie came together because I wonder if
any of this has to do with Sam Elliott's
actual life yeah cuz I know he does a
lot of voiceover now and I don't see him
a lot in movies that's how I could see
her comparison with the wrestler yeah I
was like this kind of seems like a thing
Mickey Rourke would be going through
yeah I bet he's gonna be [ __ ] amazing
yeah I think they're gonna make a
trilogy Bill Murray lost in translation
make you work in the wrestler and Sam
Elliott in the year the washed-up dudes
Nick Offerman man has his beard always
changes Nick Offerman man I [ __ ] love
him in parks in Iraq he's never said oh
[ __ ] I don't know if I've seen him it is
complete the best character in parts of
recreation he is the funniest one for
sure
I know people lose their [ __ ]
Ron Swanson I'm gonna have to watch it
he looks more like a buddy here yeah
which is interesting to see that sign of
his personality and I remember seeing a
stand-up or anything or even seen him in
interviews so when I watch like Parks
and Rec and he has a very specific
demeanor to seem like lightening up and
being fun and like a holy [ __ ] you have
a person I thought that was your thing I
always get this vibe off him he's like a
very committed action yeah and one of
those guys who like can do everything
because yeah it's like he does like
sketch comedy and stuff on TV but
there's also the stand-up it now isn't
like a drama yeah I'm always fascinated
when those dudes can really hop around
and Krysten Ritter
yeah totally the wrestler having to make
it with your dog yeah I don't mean to
keep comparing it but it all looks great
though it all looks very effective and
it looks like a thing that will really
tell you your hearts because a movie
they'll put you on kind of an emotional
journey but it feels like bittersweet
you know it'll make you think about life
and then and career and family do you
really want to be an actor in traffic
and the beach there's gonna be a time
where we won't see Tom Cruise doing
crazy stunts and then what is he gonna
do you know he's gonna do stunts in the
hospice care Oh dudes I feel like
Kristin Ritter is roll it doesn't look
like it's very big this looks very big
it doesn't seem like it's a real
challenging role for her someone of her
caliber to go from Jane and Breaking Bad
to Jessica Jones and then like oh you're
the daughter who he has to make amends
with yeah yeah I'm sure she can
I'm sure she'll nail it yeah I'm not
concerned that she but this is a good
step for her for being like a TV star to
do it yeah overall I think this is a
good like supporting role give her I'll
give it that this is yeah it's a step up
in calibre it'll probably broaden out
the kinds of roles people would consider
her for you know a mentor that humpy
dumpy hands do that Donna from the IRA
forgot her name this is Laura lighter
than me
Oh Laura Laura pretty pawn I haven't
seen her in anything since that 70 show
you might orange is the new black right
I've seen a couple episodes she's yeah
she's in that [ __ ] I don't think for any
problem is she yeah she's got like
blonde hair and like cornrows she was
really cool in that 70 show though yeah
yeah she seems like a cool chick she's
like really I haven't seen that many
I've only seen the episode of that 70s
show that Mitch Hedberg in it oh man
dude Ashton Kutcher and Wilmer
Valderrama and Topher Grace are so funny
and the guy who plays the dad also the
stone her friend who doesn't really do
much Danny Masterson yeah interesting
dynamic yeah you know older man with a
younger with a significantly younger
woman yeah yeah but you still got it man
so God that gives me hope I could find
love at 71 if I don't find love until
I'm 70 again hey man holy [ __ ] but hey
it's never too late it seems like they
both got issues then that bridges the
gap between their agents yeah listen if
I'm 70 and rich I could go for a gold
digger and what do you know that I'll be
okay with that if I'm still single and
lonely no kids listen guys you can
subscribe see the real rejects why not
it's free the [ __ ] do you got to lose
you don't have to watch the videos we
just like a flashy subscriber channel
thanks you too thanks hey Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum House in the real region
real rejects and bloom house and I can't
say much but we got a special Schmo down
match coming up soon Omo
boy am i soon that could be a few weeks
right now who knows but we know who
we're going up against you never know
and oh man is it gonna be special it's a
special occasion you could say there are
two toasts